MILA BERNABO: Please join
me in welcoming Poppy.
[APPLAUSE]
POPPY JAMIE: OK, Hi, everyone.
First of all, just
thank you for having me.
It is such an honor
be talking at Google.
And even more
exciting because you
guys are the first ever
to experience and have
a sneak preview of
the Happy Not Perfect
app on Android, which will
be launching this week
as a live beta on Google Play
in light of Mental Health
Awareness Week.
So yesterday, I began to think--
it's funny-- I'm about to
speak to some of the smartest
people in the entire world who
dedicate their time, expertise,
and talent into making our
technological experiences
amazing.
The care and attention put in
means our devices constantly
improve, amaze, and delight us,
and quickly adapt to our needs.
That care and attention
carries through from developer
to the consumer.
I know if I don't charge
my phone, it will die.
When a new update comes
out, I immediately
spend time upgrading
and look in awe
at new features and functions.
But when thinking about this,
I thought, isn't it odd?
We clearly all understand
the basic concept
that care, time,
and attention is
needed to make anything better.
But most of us are not
willing to apply this concept
to the most, most important
hardware that exists--
our minds.
Unlike our
technological devices,
we don't recharge ourselves.
We assume we can just work
harder without a break.
We learn an operating system
as children and stick with it.
Imagine if we were stuck
using Windows 94 today--
nightmare.
It's strange, right, how
we learn thinking patterns
at an early age from the
circumstances we're in,
or the people around us?
And many just accept
that for life.
Your parents could be the
smartest people in the world,
but are they really
the right ones
to mold your thinking forever?
I believe our minds and our
thinking require the same care
and attention as we
put into upgrading
our technological devices.
As your life changes, surely,
your thinking needs to also.
So today, I'm going to be
speaking about Happy Not
Perfect, a company I founded
a few years ago, purely
dedicated to looking after
your mind and your thinking.
Because as I'm
sure you can agree,
it's easy to forget that our own
hardware needs to be rewired,
recharged, and rested.
So who wants to feel less
stressed, sleeping better,
and making decisions
with a calmer mindset--
anyone?
AUDIENCE: OK.
POPPY JAMIE: Great, let's
see if we can help out.
So I thought before I launch
into the tools we've developed,
I thought I'd begin by telling
you a little bit about why
I'm here.
I know we heard a brief
[INAUDIBLE] earlier.
I grew up in a really
unique environment--
mother being a psychotherapist
and a father an entrepreneur,
he suffered from severe
stress and anxiety.
And from a young
age, I was taught
our emotional health was
delicate, and saw firsthand
how stress and anxiety not only
affects an individual, how it
spreads quickly between people.
I watched my mother dedicate her
life to learning new therapies
to pass on to my father.
We would wake up and she
would say, brush her teeth,
wash your face.
Now how will you look
after your mind today?
Meditation, breathing,
walking outside,
were as normal as
eating in our household.
And later on, I
became a TV presenter.
Three years ago,
I launched a show
called "Pillowtalk with Poppy."
[CLICKS TONGUE] And from
that, did I realize,
when I started to read messages
being sent to me from people
all around the world, didn't
matter their age or location
or gender-- so many of these
messages said the same things.
I'm stressed.
I'm worried about home, work,
family, friends, relationships,
the future.
And I could relate.
I was feeling it myself.
The constant feeling of needing
to try harder, be more, look
more, keep up.
This sparked me to
research further
and I began to look into
the macro mental health data
trends.
And what I found changed the
course of my life forever.
Things were even
worse than I imagined.
We are in a mental and an
emotional health epidemic.
Stress and anxiety is
at an all-time high.
According to the American
Psychological Association,
millennials are
the most stressed
out generation
that's ever lived.
And sadly, this has risen
again by another 5% this year.
Is it social media?
Why is this happening?
The fact we're on comparison
overload, information overload.
And studies have
proven those who
spend more time scrolling
tend to have lower self-esteem
and high levels of
stress and anxiety.
Is it just because life has
got more stressful in general?
John S. Price, a psychiatrist--
he advises his clients
to actually stop
watching television news,
noting "climate change,
nuclear apocalypse, Ebola,
flesh-eating viruses,
antibiotic resistance,
ever-growing economic
inequality, fake news--
the list is endless.
It's too much for people
to hear on a daily basis."
And some say humans
in Western societies
are becoming more
psychologically sensitive
because there is less pressure
on us to survive now that food
and water are so abundant.
They believe our gaze has
moved away from survival
and shifted inward
and so we're suffering
from internal problems more.
So whether it's the
likes of manipulating
our self-worth, the
bombardment of perfect images,
the over-stimulation, the
fact we know what our sister's
boyfriend's mother's
grandmother's dog owner's
child is having for breakfast,
whatever the reason be is,
three years ago, I thought, this
can't be now what we call life.
That we can't except
this as our reality--
highly stressed, anxious, not
feeling enough and terrified
of real connection.
No, I refuse.
I need to create some
sort of solution.
So with the help and inspiration
of my mum's focus on the mind,
I tracked down a neuroscientist,
my CEO, a brain cognitive app
game developer, and we started
building Happy Not Perfect.
We wanted it to be a mind
gym, to help us build muscles,
those inner happiness muscles.
To help us strengthen
our emotional resilience,
the bounce-back skill
in the face of setback.
A gym to help us take back
the control of our minds
and get off this roller coaster,
the roller coaster of emotions
many of us continually sit
on, just waiting for life
to happen.
You may know the feeling--
you're strapped in.
You sit there excitedly
as your carriage moves up.
It's moving up.
Things seem to be going really
well, and at the same time,
you're slightly and
constantly in fear something
might go wrong, and the
drop is about to happen.
Yes, got a bonus, going on
a date, epic night out--
no, missed the deadline
and you're at the bottom.
We don't need to be on this
roller coaster of emotion.
We can step off.
But we need to have the
tools and practice to do so.
And the good news
is, science has
proved we don't need to
be on a constant roller
coaster of emotion.
With the magic of
neuroplasticity,
meaning our brains are
really like plastic--
we can mold, we can rewire.
Just like if you wanted
to change your body,
you would have to
commit to working out,
your brain is exactly the same.
It's not a click
of your fingers--
suddenly, you're
running a marathon.
Sadly, you've got to train.
We can't just wake up
and expect to feel good.
Feeling good takes work
and it takes dedication.
You have to choose to
take action to feel good.
So instead of finding all the
tools in different places--
meditation over here,
breathwork, diary there--
Happy Not Perfect set
about to combine many tools
supported by positive
psychology and research studies
into one place so you can take
your mindfulness happy gym
in your pocket everywhere.
So I'm going to take
you through the app
so you can experience your very
own full mind workout, which
we call the refresh.
And it aims to relax,
process thoughts,
and find a positive perspective
in less than five minutes.
It's a daily ritual.
So we have to reset our
default because our default,
our caveman minds, they
are fundamentally negative.
For evolutionary
reasons, we were trained
to look for the negative first.
For example, I would
walk into an environment
and I would look for the threat.
And I would see a
lion over there,
and I would think danger,
danger, danger, danger.
Let's retreat.
And so as a consequence,
we have evolved
to reportedly have about
70% negative thoughts
in our outlook.
But in 2018, there
aren't any lions
hanging out on Spring Street,
aside from a toxic boss.
So we don't need to
have this negative bias.
The refresh workout is designed
to upgrade your hardware.
The useful thing about
this is that you can
do at home, at work, on the go.
You don't have to
close your eyes.
So let's jump into it.
Here is your home screen.
And you can either, obviously,
choose to take a refresh,
or you can listen to
our daily dose, which
is a thought for the
day, some positive wisdom
to change your outlook.
I love this quote--
Marianne Williamson
says, "a miracle is just
a shift in perspective."
And the daily dose
hopes to give you
a shift in perspective
every single day.
But let's jump into the refresh.
Step one-- how do you feel?
Now studies found that just
by acknowledging how you feel,
you actually start slowing
down the emotional center
of your brain, the amygdala.
And we have over 25 emotions
you can choose from.
And it's amazing how much we
go through life on autopilot.
We never check in with
actually how we feel.
You walk into the office and
someone says, how are you?
And you're like, yeah, I'm good.
But you're not.
You're actually still really
fucked up from yesterday.
And anyways, so for the
purposes of this talk,
I'm selecting that I'm
feeling stressed, as I'm very
stressed about public speaking.
And step two-- and that's--
it's crazy, so simple.
Just choose your
emotion and you start
activating your brain
in a way that you
can feel more balanced--
so simple.
Step two-- breathe.
Now I want to do a little
experiment before we launch
into the breathing
step and to see
how well you guys breathe, OK?
So can you all give me a big
inhale how and a big exhale.
So who felt themselves
go up on the inhale
and down on the exhale?
Fantastic-- I'm so glad you're
here, because you're all
terrible breathers.
And don't worry-- nine out of
10 people are bad breathers,
and this is what I
found so insane to me.
I went to go train with
a breathing instructor
under one of the world's
leading specialists, Dr. Belisa
Vranich.
And she educated me on
how badly our breathing
habits have become.
And usually, we get into
bad breathing habits
from the age of five years
old, because we go to school,
we hunch over desks.
And as a consequence, all
our breath goes up here.
So when people start
breathing like this,
you're moving neck
and shoulders,
but your neck and shoulders
are not breathing muscles.
Your breathing muscles are here.
So it makes no sense that
we spend all day, every day,
going like this.
And all that's doing is hiking
up our cortisol, the stress
hormone, impacting
our immune system
and making us feel
more stressed.
So immediately, when we
start consciously breathing
and we belly breathe,
we're able to stimulate
our vagus nerve that takes us
out of the fight and flight
system into the rest
and relax system.
So I want us all to give--
do a belly breath together.
So hands on your belly.
And I want you, on the inhale,
to expand as if a balloon is
inside your lungs.
So inhale, expand, and exhale.
Squeeze all the air out.
Belly to spine-- inhale.
Expand your belly.
Exhale.
Belly to spine--
squeeze all the air out.
Now let's do that again.
Inhale.
Now try and sip
some more air in.
And exhale, relax
your shoulders.
You notice a slight
difference in how
you're breathing just then?
Yes, nod-- great.
So in the app, it not only
tells you how to breathe.
And also through biofeedback,
just relaxing your shoulders,
you're using your body to send
messages to your brain to say,
I'm not in danger.
A lion is not attacking me.
I'm safe.
And then you're able to
breathe for either 30
seconds, a minute.
And again, we wanted to make
sure this was super visually
stimulating, rather than
what I kind of found
when I was looking around the
market for kind of breathing
tools.
I found them all pretty boring.
Step three-- journaling.
This, again, may seem so
simple, this exercise.
But if I told you all that
I invented the sit-up,
you'd be like, what?
That's so basic.
It's just a body
moving up and down.
And this is what's so
incredible about mindfulness
is that the most
simplest of activities
have such an amazing
positive impact on your mind.
So when you journal and actually
allow yourself to write down
how you're feeling, you
start activating the computer
side of your brain,
your prefrontal cortex,
and that helps calm the
emotional center even more,
furthering your movement into
the rest and relax state.
They say a problem shared
is a problem halved,
and it is really true.
You're able to create
that rational distance
between what's been happening
in your life and processing it.
So in the app, it allows
you-- it gives you
a different question
depending on the emotion you
select at the beginning.
The experience is
tailored to your mood.
So I wrote I'm about
to speak at Google
and I really hope I don't
fuck this up-- great.
And then, the whole
screen explodes
because I was so fascinated
by burning ceremonies.
But I thought to myself,
well, health and safety.
I don't want anybody to
be burning down houses.
I just thought I'd
put it in an app.
So we worked really
hard to make sure
that you could have your
own mini-burning ritual
and then visually can see
yourself letting go of worries.
What I find incredible
about human beings
is that we really like
to handicap ourselves.
We experience all these
emotions on a day-to-day basis,
and yet we never kind of
process them and let them go.
It's like we have an emotional
backpack that we keep
filling up every single day.
And after a while, that
backpack gets very heavy.
So why not allow
yourself to release
every single day a little bit
and make the load lighter,
make life easier for yourself?
Step four-- what are
you grateful for?
Now look, I know you
can go on Instagram
and see a lot of
smug #blessed posts,
but this is not about that.
Your grateful diary
is incredible.
It not only helps
stimulate positive hormones
and helps you sleep better.
Studies found that
people go to sleep
with a more positive mental
attitude tend to have a better
quality of sleep.
So doing this
before bed is great.
But what I really think is
amazing behind the science
behind gratitude is the ability
to set your brain filters.
Now I'm not sure if this
has ever happened to you,
but let's say you
purchase a red car.
And you're driving in your
red car and you suddenly go,
everybody has bought a red car.
I am a trendsetter.
And sadly, you're
not a trendsetter.
No more red cars
are on the road.
Just red cars are
more relevant to you.
We have so much information
being fired at us
on a day-to-day
basis, our brain is
so clever, it kind of
does the Google search
for us-- like, what is
relevant, what is not,
what should I take notes
of, what should I not?
So by writing a
grateful diary, you
set your own filters
to say, actually,
looking for things that
are good in my life
is now going to become
relevant information.
Set your own Google filters--
write a grateful diary
every single day.
It is incredible.
Step five-- game time.
Now games are fantastic at
interrupting negative thought
loops.
It is a different type of
mindfulness experience.
You're focusing on
one thing rather than
our kind of ADHD
generation, when
you're thinking about lots of
things, which can be stressful.
So we allow you to play a
different game every day.
We have a kind of a
coloring-it-in activity.
And I was fascinated by the
research around art therapy.
Step six-- self-compassion.
Now I just want to ask
you a question-- how many
of you in the first half
an hour of waking up
go on your social media
to scroll through feeds?
Yeah, OK, so, yeah, a good
amount-- yeah, 80% of you.
And let's just have a think
about that ritual, OK?
So we wake up every single
day and we go to our phone.
So before we've even checked
in with our self, even thought
about ourselves,
we're immediately
thinking about other people.
After years of
doing this day in,
day out, all we do is
like everybody else,
like everybody else.
Of course, that is going to have
an effect on our self-esteem.
Not for one moment do we think
to ourselves, what do we have?
Like, what's good?
We just go, oh, yeah,
she's got a great holiday.
Awesome, she looks
great, awesome.
I'm double-tapping
everybody else.
So I'm like, no--
self-compassion.
Double-tap yourself.
And so this step is all
about double-tapping yourself
and building up your resilience.
And step seven-- make
someone else feel good.
It's amazing in our
narcissistic world
how little we
think about others.
And every-- so many
studies will show
that people that think about
others the most are happier.
Now you will see on
your seats, you actually
have a physical vibe card.
And I hope that you will
give that to somebody today.
Pay it forward.
And we have the same philosophy
on the app-- every single day,
the app asks you, who can
you send a positive note to?
It's incredible how much
you can change someone's day
by just letting them know
you're thinking about them.
And so this allows you to
send positive messages.
And you did it.
In under five minutes, you
did a full mind workout,
stimulating your
prefrontal cortex,
relaxing and calming your
amygdala, the emotional center,
helped you stimulate serotonin.
And you didn't have
to close your eyes.
There is no reason
why you shouldn't
be doing this every single day.
Now aside from the refresh,
we have a meditation library.
And I was fascinated
about meditation
because I felt that it was
something we all want to do,
but we all kind of forget.
Because as soon as you wake
up and you've got the alarm,
and suddenly you're
like, oh, god,
I need to see that
person later and I've
to respond to this email
and I've to do this.
I've got to do this.
Suddenly, our entire
morning is gone.
Those that have a
meditation practice--
it's incredible.
There's again, so much
research behind meditation
helping us to calm the
emotional center more.
It even lengthens your
telomeres, which in your brain,
can help prevent--
it can help prevent the
slowdown of cell rejuvenation.
So it can help in anti-aging.
I mean, isn't that crazy?
You don't need an
anti-aging cream anymore.
You just need to meditate.
But I wanted to
make meditation fun.
So we did a ton of focus groups.
And I said, well,
what do you really
want to hear meditations about?
And they were like,
well, actually,
[SIGHS] how to bounce
back from rejection,
or removing exes--
good riddance.
And I was like,
yeah, done, cool--
the fuck-it meditation.
Yeah, we're going
to put it in there.
So we really wanted to
bring some personality
to mental wellness because
it can become very boring.
So we have lots there for you--
Three Days to Bounce Back From
Rejection-- one of my faves.
Jody Shield-- fantastic guide.
But the thing is with
all of these kind
of mindfulness rituals
is that they only
really work with repetition.
Just like if you wanted
to train for a marathon,
you would have to
train every single day.
Just like keeping
your teeth healthy,
we all know at the
age of five, we
need to brush our
teeth every single day.
And just like
learning the piano--
requires practice.
So if you want to develop
a positive mental outlet,
optimistic thinking,
it requires practice.
Caring for yourself
is really not selfish.
You are massively
doing us all a favor.
And so, we have
a mission to make
sure looking after our mind
is as normal, easy, and fun
as brushing the teeth.
Emotional education, awareness
around mental well-being,
can change the world.
But it really starts
at an individual level.
It requires us all to look after
and upgrade our own hardware,
to stop behavior and negative
thought patterns being passed
through generations
as learnt behaviors.
But for us all to
wake up and realize
we have the power
over what we think.
And OK, we have
moments of struggling,
but we can all do
something about it.
So thank you for listening.
I hope you enjoy the app.
Please share it with
friends and family.
If there's anyone here
who'd like to collaborate,
help spread the word
through Google Play,
I'd be really grateful.
Thank you for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
MILA BERNABO: Thank you so much.
That was very cool, to see
all the different steps.
My favorite part, and
I encourage all of you,
because you couldn't see
it while on the screen--
do the burn--
that is my favorite
thing on the app.
I'm curious, Poppy,
what surprised you most
from the research when you first
started developing the app?
POPPY JAMIE: How, to
be honest, little we
know about our own mind.
I started doing research just
asking people, what's anxiety?
And nobody would even be able
to tell me what anxiety was.
And I thought that's so crazy.
You go to school.
You learn how to brush--
you learn how to read and write.
But yet no one tells you
how to be a human being.
No one tells you how to
deal with and process loss.
That's all going to happen.
It's going to
happen to all of us,
or a break-up, social
rejection, disappointment.
And that's what I've
found so phenomenal,
is how little we knew about the
thing that controls our mind.
MILA BERNABO:
Right, right, right.
And was there anything
in your research,
and then in developing the app,
parts that, different exercises
that you cut out, or you
wish you could have included?
Or was this sort of
the final product
that you were super happy with?
I'm curious is
there was anything
else you were considering.
POPPY JAMIE: So I
feel like my CEO would
be laughing right
now because I think
we are always on a constant--
that's the beauty of app
developing, is that I'm like,
can we go to Mars already?
And he's, like, no, Poppy,
we're building the rocket.
And so we had to put in
the fundamental features
I really felt were absolutely
necessary in everybody
needing to look after
their mind at stage one.
And then we have a
whole kind of blueprint
about where we're going to go.
But really, when
we were thinking
about this whole philosophy
about a mind gym,
like a normal gym,
if we were going
to set up a gym right
now, we would be like,
OK, maybe we need
a running machine--
OK, sure.
Maybe we need some
weights-- great.
So that's what we can did.
We're like, what
are the necessaries,
and then we'll have our kind
of luxury items coming soon.
MILA BERNABO: Great.
Is there anything you can share
with us of what's coming next
for Happy Not Perfect?
Or should we just stay tuned?
[LAUGHS]
POPPY JAMIE: Stay
tuned, stay tuned.
[LAUGHS]
MILA BERNABO: Perfect, perfect.
I'd love to also hear
a little bit more
about the inspiration
for the app.
You talked about your mom,
which I love that story.
Can you tell us a bit more
about your personal experience
with stress, with anxiety?
You juggle two
companies and brands,
and what is this like
in your day-to-day life?
POPPY JAMIE: It's
interesting, actually--
Happy Not Perfect is--
I don't know how I'd
live without it now.
Because I used to
love buying journals,
and the five-minute journal,
I loved, for example--
it asked different questions.
But I found that
I would lose them
and that I would be absolutely
mortified if someone read it.
And it was so impractical.
And also, I loved
a self-help book,
but then I thought,
oh, my god, if somebody
looks on my bookcase, they're
like, who is this girl?
She's got some serious issues.
[LAUGHS] So it's really--
to have something,
a tool that I'm
able to use every
single day to balance
all the different things
I'm doing has just been--
it's just been phenomenal.
And something I really,
really do kind of--
you know, I said,
I use it myself.
And I just think it's
interesting we live in
a such a different world.
I say we had the Industrial
Revolution, humanity totally
changed the way we lived life.
And then we had this
technological revolution.
And again, we are living
in a very different world
to where we were 20 years ago.
So I feel passionately
about us all
adapting to this new, very
fast-paced world in order
for us to survive in a happy
way, rather than struggling.
MILA BERNABO:
Sure, sure, and are
there any other daily
rituals that you
do in self-care to manage?
POPPY JAMIE: Yeah, I'm a major
fan of walking meditations.
I will usually, before I even
brush my teeth, I'll be-- just
do a 15-minute
walk when I wake up
because it just
kind of brings me
slowly, nice into the
world away from my sleep.
And it just helps
calm everything.
So I'm a major fan of walking.
If I can walk-- like
rain, snow, shine,
I'm there, out there
with some trainers.
I feel like that's
massively helpful.
And also, because obviously,
so many of us have office jobs,
it's incredible how
little daylight we get.
And actually, daylight
is so important
to be stimulating our
vitamin D. So just getting
outside, regardless
of the weather,
is so critical to
feeling better.
MILA BERNABO: Mm, I love that.
We need to get out
of here more often.
[LAUGHTER]
We have beautiful terraces, but
there's a world outside Google
to explore.
A couple years ago, you did
a TEDx talk on our addiction
to likes, which
you talked about,
sort of social media and
the effect of technology
on our well-being.
And here, being at Google,
I'm curious, how do you
manage your own sort of
relationship with social media,
with technology?
Do you have any advice for
all of us on what to do?
POPPY JAMIE: I think it's--
again, it's so interesting,
because we didn't really
need to think about this
until, I would say, maybe
in the last year and a half.
Because we were all--
it was interesting.
We were just-- it
was like a new toy,
and we didn't know what
it was really doing to us.
And now, I did the
TED talk on addicted
to likes, a couple of years ago
I really started to notice how
obviously those
little [CLICKS TONGUE]
double taps triggering the
dopamine release in your brain.
You wanting more.
And how kind of bad you can feel
if you don't get as many as you
want to get, and whatever.
So as a consequence,
I really try
to do social media-free
weekends just
because it helps me be
more present with everybody
I'm around.
Because I think it's--
everybody noticed the
person at the table.
That attention goes as soon
as they get out their device.
And then kind of the
conversation and the attention
shifts.
So I try and do social
media-free weekends.
And that's the thing--
technology is amazing.
I think sometimes it can
get a really bad rep.
But it's how we use it a lot
is causing us the problems.
So if we can balance everything.
If we ate too much,
we'd feel unhealthy.
Or it's like anything in
life-- everything in moderation
is brilliant, right?
MILA BERNABO: Sure,
sure, wonderful.
And sort of turning
to you a little bit,
I'd love to hear about your
personal sort of journey
from television
hosting personality
through to your
accessory line, and now,
the mindfulness
mental health app.
Sort of what was that like?
What led you from
one step to another?
POPPY JAMIE: So,
it's interesting,
because I feel like my entire
life was building up to really
creating Happy Not Perfect.
And everything I was
doing at the TV hosting
was like the
six-year-old dream I had.
I was like, I can't wait
to host television shows.
And it was really
fun and exciting,
but there was this
point where it just felt
desperately under-fulfilling.
How am I helping the world?
And I just felt like if
I died being a TV host,
I would be just,
like, oh, great.
And also, I was really bad.
Honestly, I failed
at every interview.
So I don't think I would have
had a very long career, anyway,
so I think I kind
of had to change.
And also, being-- what
is so lovely about this,
and I think I'm so grateful to
be working with an amazing team
that we can create something
like Happy Not Perfect
and get it to life, is
the messages we receive.
In that we just had a beta--
sorry, on iOS, sorry.
But we get e-mails
every single day
from people saying, thank you.
I've never slept so well.
I have finally got
over my breakup.
I've finally got
a peace of mind.
This is getting me
through hospital.
And that feels so rewarding.
So and look, start-ups
are a nightmare.
Even with the fashion
line, it is brutal.
You're working-- and I'm
sure everyone in this room
understands how
difficult it is to--
you're working on really,
obviously, exciting--
and we're so lucky to
have the jobs we have.
But they take their
pound of flesh.
And that's interesting, talking
about mental well-being--
you're seven days
a week, but when
it's kind of fueled
by a passion that you
know that you can
help other people,
I think it just makes
it a lot easier.
MILA BERNABO: Mm, I love that.
I was also reading
about in 2017,
that you are named one of
"Forbes" 30 under 30s--
congratulations.
And you were appointed
as the youngest board
member of the Resnick
Psychiatric Hospital Advisory
Board.
I'd love to just hear-- at UCLA.
I'd love to hear more about
what that experience was
like, what your work
is like with them,
and what you're learning
from that experience.
POPPY JAMIE: UCLA is such
an incredible institution.
And it's been fascinating
and a real honor
to kind of see behind the scenes
and how the hospital supports
the university.
And they have the
Depression Grand Challenge.
They have the Healthy
Campus Initiative.
And they are proactively,
as a university,
doing everything
they can to support
student mental well-being.
Mental well-being amongst
the student population
is really at an all-time low.
And I'm not surprised
because I think
this pressure to be successful
is so enormous, especially at--
these universities are
really difficult to get into.
There is this feeling
of keeping up.
Everything has to be perfect.
And the stress these students
are putting on themselves
is unmanageable.
So for me, it's really lovely to
try and support in all the ways
I can.
Also being 28 myself,
it wasn't so long
ago that I was a student.
And I was actually a TV
presenting at the time,
so I was balancing these two
jobs of university and work,
and trying to do that.
And the "Forbes" thing, I was--
that's just a real honor--
yeah, real honor, like, lucky.
MILA BERNABO: Amazing.
Before I'm going to
ask one more question,
then I invite the
audience if you
want to line up at mics
if you have any questions.
We'd love to hear from you.
So if you could take over
the Google sort home page,
the landing page,
and either do--
POPPY JAMIE: Cool!
Can I?
[LAUGHS]
MILA BERNABO: [LAUGHS]
We'll look into it.
And if you could
either design a doodle
or have some sort of phrase
on there, what would it be?
What would your message
to be to the world?
POPPY JAMIE: Tell someone
you love them today.
Because I just think
we go through life--
and it sounds so cringe.
But it's so true--
we go through life thinking
about ourselves a lot.
When you're feeling
stressed or anxious,
you're thinking about yourself.
So I think that
actually, when we
turn the attention
outward to whose day can I
make better today?
Who can I help today?
Life is easier because you are
able to support other people.
And to be honest, what is
life-- why is life worth living?
It's for our friendships,
our relationships, our true,
authentic social connections.
So yes, tell someone you love
them today, I think, 'cause--
I wonder how many people would.
I kind of love it.
MILA BERNABO: I love that.
You should all do that today.
You have two homework
assignments-- the card
and tell someone you love them.
POPPY JAMIE: Yeah,
you know what?
If you have your phone on
you, why doesn't everybody
get out their phone and
send one message to someone
to tell them that
you appreciate them.
MILA BERNABO: Right
now, in real time.
POPPY JAMIE: Yeah,
just one, like, thanks.
Hope you're well.
If someone's going
through a break-up--
that kind of thing.
Thinking of you.
I heard you were sick last week.
Are you better?
I'm sure you have-- you
don't need any more prompts.
MILA BERNABO: We'll give you
20 seconds [LAUGHS] to come up
with a very thoughtful message.
POPPY JAMIE: And
that's what brilliant
about positive messages, is
they have a boomerang effect.
You send them and you'll get
a message about being like,
thank you so much.
Oh my god, someone actually
thought about me today.
MILA BERNABO: Mm, great.
I'm also curious, Poppy, where
did you come up with the name?
And were there other names
you were considering?
How did Happy Not
Perfect really stick?
How did that speak to you?
POPPY JAMIE: Well, Happy
Not Perfect kind of found me
in a weird sort of way.
I woke up in the middle
of the night, 3:00 AM.
And I just was like--
honestly, I was possessed.
And I just went online and
bought the domain name.
And I couldn't believe Happy
Not Perfect was free in 2015.
I was like, that's crazy.
I didn't even know what
it was going to be.
I just had these words--
happy not perfect.
And I just think that I was
really suffering at the time
from just not
understanding, I suppose,
and not prioritizing
my own happiness,
but wanting to be perfect
for everybody around me.
Whether it was for work or my
friends or family or whatever,
and I think we can get ourselves
into not helpful patterns.
I-- and I quote this from
Oprah-- the disease to please.
And Happy Not Perfect
really spoke to me.
And I suddenly thought,
my god, imagine
if I focused on what
made me happy today
rather than trying
to be perfect.
Wouldn't life be different?
And I just thought, well, my
dream would be for everybody
in this world to see the
words Happy Not Perfect
every single day, just
to remind them of that.
You know what?
Today, your happiness
matters above all else.
MILA BERNABO: Yep.
Was there a tipping
point for you
when you sort of had that
personal experience of hey,
I'm not happy and I
feel like I'm just
needing to be perfect
for the world around me.
Was there a specific moment
or time in your life,
or was it sort of a progression?
POPPY JAMIE: You know what?
I think it's one
of those things.
Sometimes don't I
think we all realize
how kind of toxic
our environments
are until we hit rock bottom.
And that was really, again,
part of the mission of Happy Not
Perfect.
Why do we need to hit
rock bottom to then start
looking after our mind?
You hit rock bottom and
then you see a therapist.
You hit rock bottom
then find medication.
But actually what is your
preventative measures?
And that was the thing--
I did.
I experienced terrible burnout.
I had to go to hospital.
I was exhausted for weeks.
And I thought to
myself, how have
I let myself get to this point
of being totally adrenally
fatigued that I'm so burnout
because I've just worked
every single hour of the day
trying to do my best, which
was kind of manic, really.
So yes, so Happy Not
Perfect is also kind
of the symbol of like, it's OK.
You can take a breath today.
You can.
You're not going to
miss out on anything.
MILA BERNABO: Wonderful, and
is there a specific challenge
or thing that you're focusing
on right now in your life that's
most present for you?
POPPY JAMIE: Yeah, I'm
trying to, at the moment,
work on stillness.
And stillness don't necessarily
mean-- what I'm learning--
to stay still.
But actually, be
in flow with life.
Because let's say kind of your--
you were looking at something
and all these objects
were moving at exactly
the same time towards you.
They would actually look as
if they were kind of still.
And that's what I'm
really interested in--
how do we cultivate
kind of more stillness,
being more aware of just
being in flow with life?
So yeah, that's what I'm
working on at the moment--
MILA BERNABO:
Wonderful, I love that.
POPPY JAMIE: --in this journey.
MILA BERNABO: All of this is.
And just to wrap up, are there
any sort of final messages
or anything you want our
audience to know about the app,
about the work you're
doing, any takeaways?
POPPY JAMIE: Please
share the word.
I just think that really
looking after our mind has
to be as normal as
looking after our bodies,
looking after our
teeth, washing our hair.
It has to be as kind of like
mundane and normal as that.
And I think we're in
a time in the world
with so much happening that
it's not only our responsibility
to look after our own, but
also to encourage people
to look after theirs, too.
So look, meditation isn't
always an option for everyone.
That's why we've
created different tools.
It is a joint effort.
We're in this together.
And look, emotions
are contagious.
So if my friend starts looking
after their mental well
being better, it's going to
make me feel better, too.
So we're very closely--
human beings are so
delicate and so sensitive,
and we're so closely
linked to each other.
So yeah, just we're
in this together.
MILA BERNABO:
Wonderful, wonderful.
Thank you, Poppy, so
much for your time,
for sharing your app.
Thank you all for coming
and taking a time out
from your day, taking a
breath-- a belly breath, not
a shoulder breath.
POPPY JAMIE: A belly
breath-- oh yeah,
belly breathing-- that's
the last message, just
belly breathing, yeah.
MILA BERNABO: Wonderful,
thank you all,
and feel free to
stick around if you
have any questions you want
to ask of Poppy directly
at the end.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
POPPY JAMIE: Thank you.
Thank you.